[Music]
listen the store is mine
i can close whatever i want and no one
can say [ __ ]
i love you too
a gorilla yeah a gorilla
a gorilla someone had a costume no
a real gorilla probably escaped from the
zoo or something i don't know
is there a security camera here maybe we
could see the footage
the gorilla took it what
[Music]
you're just gonna go a wild boar could
have held water
yeah but a gorilla come on really
oh
[Music]
and you'll be its director what do you
mean by that
and how are we supposed to do that this
here is a zoo without animals
and we'll buy some new ones how much do
we need
i know that i was gonna check if there
are any used tigers on ebay
i have a really good idea are you out of
your mind
do you really think this whole thing's
gonna work
we need very realistic costumes
remember practice makes perfect
they should look really real put them on
no one would ever assume that there are
fake animals in a zoo they should look
as alive as possible
i'm your man
say hello lion what the hell are you
even doing here huh this is so stupid
that looked really good you look like a
real gorilla
really it's going in the water don't get
your fair wet that costs a lot of money
[Music]
a polar bear that drinks coke whoever
heard of them
well maybe there were things that seemed
weird what kind of things
real gorilla probably escaped from the
zoo or something i don't know
is there security camera footage
the gorilla took it
[Music]
bye